if only it were this quick and easy to
get around Malaysia's capital city Kuala
lumper in reality rush-hour looks more
like this co2 emissions produced by
traffic are one of Malaysia's biggest
climate killers but that's all set to
change for example with this electric
scooter it was developed by the
Malaysian company eek limo they're
especially proud of the high-performance
batteries they designed themselves
the power direct drive on a mortal is
six kilowatt the batteries that we use
is four kilowatt hour this is one of the
the technology breakthroughs that we
have achieved so far not only comparing
Malaysia I would say they're comparing
to the world the Malaysian government
supports companies that bring
eco-friendly products onto the market
like a clean mo the financial aid and
tax breaks are supposed to help Malaysia
become a greener country but over the
past three and a half years only four
hundred scooters have left the factory
at around three thousand seven hundred
euros they cost twice as much as
conventional models our business model
right now is to go for the fleet
customers who heavily use two wheelers
right now the biggest is Kentucky Fried
Chicken KFC KFC are using it for home
deliveries there is a police team
patrolling using in a bikes and we also
have a local council enforcement team
going around patrolling the roads we
have not entered the consumer market so
far it's only for the fleet customers
they're already in use at the Malaysian
Ministry of Energy with support from the
gi said Germany's International
Cooperation and Development Agency the
government wants to promote other green
products with an official label to
guarantee their green credentials more
than 850 items already carry the mejia
mark the project is called Malaysia
green technology and is overseen by the
Ministry of Energy but cost is proving
to be an issue when go to the
supermarket for example they're looking
at how much this cost in comparison of
course so that is still a challenge
there so unless we have economies of
scale maybe we can produce these green
products at scale then we can reduce the
cost right now the government is the
main customer for these certified eco
products
the government's is the biggest
purchaser 15% of the GDP comes from the
government so the government set the
directions set example with the the high
purchase want to come one that will
stimulate the market in introducing
green product services for private and
green purchases based on registrations
that we have on the Mejia
we can see that the demand is increasing
demand for paints for example dream
paints green reading materials more and
more companies want to jump on the eco
bandwagon but are their products worthy
of the government's eco label that's
decided here at the renowned serum
Institute in Kuala lumper every
candidate for my hijab accreditation is
put through its paces to make sure the
product really is eco-friendly this
detergent is up next
the company claims that this product is
biodegradable so we are going to test on
the biodegradability potential according
to the OECD test matter the sample is
mixed with a bacterial culture if the
sample hasn't dissolved within 28 days
the detergent won't be granted the label
the criteria that have to be fulfilled
for the Eco label are tailored to
conditions in Malaysia not only with
respect to health and environmental
sustainability but also with respect to
economic feasibility different it has
different culture different requirements
and different standard of living so this
has to be considered because otherwise
if we set it too high like jeopardy then
second or third world country may not be
able to adapt it so we have to look into
the economic situation of the country
and how they can adapt with the with the
Eco level because equally believe if we
put too high that nobody can comply and
nobody can take it up so it defeats the
purpose of having equal level the next
step is to establish uniform ecological
standards by region the German
development agency is also supporting
Malaysia's neighboring countries
Indonesia Thailand and the Philippines
because the more people buy eco-friendly
products the better it is for the
environment
you